EVER GIVEN MAN.
NOBODY KNOWS ALL ABOUT THAT ALL
TOO WELL, HE IS THE NEW VOICE,
BY THE WAY, THE NEW CEO, A
FRIEND, MR. 99999, HERMAN CAIN.
HOW ARE YOU, SIR?
>> I'M DOING FINE, SEAN HERE I
WANT TO ADD ONE WORD TO ALL OF
THOSE RADICAL IDEAS THAT YOU
DELINEATED, AND YOU ARE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT, YOU CAN ADD
ONE MORE WORD.
THEY ARE RADICAL AND
IMPRACTICAL.
NOT ONE OF THEM IS PRACTICAL
RELATIVE TO COST OR RELATIVE TO
THE CONSTITUTION.
YOU CAN ADD THAT THE NEXT TIME
YOU DO A MONOLOGUE, WHERE HE
IDENTIFY ALL OF THESE CRAZY,
RADICAL IDEAS.
>> Sean: FROM HERMAN CAIN,
IMPRACTICAL.
GOT IT, WE WILL PUT THAT ON THE
LIST.
YOU WERE GOING TO THE FED, I WAS
HAPPY ABOUT YOU GOING TO THE
FED.
YOU AND I HAVE JOKED, WHEN YOU
ARE RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT, YOU
TALK ABOUT ALL OF A SUDDEN, YOU
START GETTING HAMMERED WITH
ALLEGATIONS, ALLEGATIONS, AND I
DON'T HAVE THE MONEY TO FIGHT
BACK, IT IS NOT AVAILABLE.
PEOPLE ARE SAYING, OH, THAT
STARTED -- IT STOPPED THE DAY
YOU GOT OUT OF THE RACE.
PRETTY INTERESTING, RIGHT?
IT WAS SO IMPORTANT.
IS THAT PART OF THE REASON, I
KNOW YOU HAVE GIVEN FIVE
REASONS, BUT I WANT TO GIVE YOU
A CHANCE TO RESPOND.
SPEAK OF THOSE ACCUSATIONS HAD
NOTHING TO DO WITH MY DECISION.
MY DECISION WAS DRIVEN BY ONE,
DURING THE PHASE ONE OF THIS
PROCESS, COLLECTING ALL THE
INFORMATION, AND ALSO FINDING
OUT FROM ADMINISTRATION STAFFERS
THE THINGS THAT I COULD AND
COULD NOT DO.
AND WHEN I STARTED TO LOOK AT
THE THINGS THAT I COULD NOT DO,
THAT IS LIKE TAKING A STALLION,
KEEPING HIM IN THE STABLE, AND
NOT LET HIM RUN.
I COULDN'T DO THE THINGS THAT I
ENJOY.
I ENJOY THE NEW VOICE, I ENJOY
MY SHOW, I ENJOY SPEAKING, I
ENJOY MY WEB SIDE, I ENJOY
WORKING WITH PEOPLE, AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY, SEAN, JUST LIKE
YOU, I ENJOY EDUCATING PEOPLE
ABOUT THE POWER OF CAPITALISM
AND HOW SOCIALISM HAS NEVER
WORKED SINCE THE HISTORY OF MAN.
IF I HAVE BECOME THE FEDERAL
RESERVE GOVERNOR  , I WOULD HAVE
BEEN LIMITED IN TERMS OF WHAT I
COULD TALK ABOUT AND TELL PEOPLE
THE TRUTH, WHEREAS IN THIS
ENVIRONMENT, I AM UNLIMITED IN
BEING ABLE TO SAY WHAT I WANT,
WHEN I WANT, TO WHOEVER IF I
WANT WHEN IT COMES TO THE TRUTH.
THAT IS WHY I MADE THE DECISION
NOT TO DO IT DO IT.
>> Sean: OKAY.
BY THE WAY, I HAVE KNOWN YOU FOR
MANY YEARS.
IT IS TRUE.
HOW MANY PEOPLE, BY THE WAY, AND
THIS IS JUST BREAKING, I JUST
GOT THIS, TRUMP SAYS HE OPPOSED
TO WHITE HOUSE AIDES TESTIFYING
TO CONGRESS.
OKAY, THIS PRESIDENT HAS NOW
GIVEN MORE DOCUMENTS, NEVER ONCE
LIKE OBAMA AND PAST PRESIDENTS,
NOT ONE TIME, DID HE INVOKE
EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE.
HE NEVER FIRED MUELLER, NEVER
FIRED ROSENSTEIN.
ALL OF THESE THINGS.
NOW THEY WANT TO JUST GO ON A
FISHING EXPEDITION.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
ENOUGH.
I DON'T THINK THE PRESIDENT
SHOULD LIFT A FINGER TO HELP
THOSE PEOPLE THAT WON'T LIFT A
FINGER TO HELP THE COUNTRY OR
SERVE THEIR CONSTITUENTS.
THEY'VE DONE THE INVESTIGATING,
AND THEY LOST.
THEY'RE A BUNCH OF CRYBABIES, IT
IS LIKE ELECTION 2016 ALL OVER
AGAIN.
>> IF I AM THE CEO OF A COMPANY,
WHICH I HAVE BEEN MANY TIMES,
AND A CEO OF MY COMPANY NOW, --
>> Sean: PRETTY BIG COMPANIES.
>> PRETTY BIG COMPANY.
>> Sean: YOU ARE RICH.
>> THEY ARE NOT ALLOWED TO GO
AND REPRESENT THEIR COMPANY BEAR
THE PRESIDENT REPRESENTS THE
COUNTRY AND ADMINISTRATION, AND
FOR THEM TO SAY THEY WANT TO BE
ABLE TO INTERROGATE AIDES IS
ABSOLUTELY RIDICULOUS.
BUT THIS FITS IN WITH ALL OF THE
OTHER RADICAL, IMPRACTICAL
IDEAS.
IN THIS PARTICULAR CASE, I WOULD
SUGGEST THAT THE PRESIDENT JUST
SIMPLY SAY NO.
THERE ISN'T ANYTHING THEY CAN DO
ABOUT IT.
>> Sean: NOT A DARN THING.
AND YOU KNOW WHAT, I THINK THE
PRESIDENT IS RIGHT, DRAWN A LINE
IN THE SAND.
ALTHOUGH, COLLUSION IN RUSSIA,
DOESN'T WORK VERY TAXES, LET'S
EMPOWER THE IRS FOR OUR
POLITICAL ENEMIES.
LET'S COLLABORATE WITH THAT
CONCEPT, STEP ON THE FIRST
AMENDMENT WHILE THEY'RE AT IT
AND ASK LAWYERS FOR THE
PRESIDENT THAT THEY'VE GOT TO
TESTIFY.